Carlos Marbach bringt Käsereien
in der Mongolei zum Erfolg.
Auch Philomena Schwab
ist auf der Gewinnerseite.
Sie ist die Überfliegerin
der Schweizer Gamerszene.
Claudio Caluori
liebt ein Leben am Limit.
Seine Bikestrecken erobern die Welt.
Ihre Geschichten sind "Schweizer
Erfolgsgeschichten - grenzenlos gut".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Keuchen *
Es sind Menschen,
die ganz nach oben wollen.
Los!
Kämpfen!
Ich bin ganz leicht am Leiden.
Menschen wie Nino Schurter,
die Weltmeister
oder Olympiasieger werden.
Aber auch Menschen
wie Claudio Caluori,
die im Schatten der Sieger
ihren eigenen Olymp erklimmen.
Und dabei
Erfolgsgeschichte schreiben.
Das war stark.
- Danke. Immer geil.
Auf dem Gipfel
seiner Sportlerkarriere
hat Caluori diese gegen
eine Unternehmerkarriere getauscht.
Man muss wohl schon ehrlich sein:
Wir haben in der Schweiz ziemliche
Vorteile beim Aufbau eines Geschäfts
und dabei, es in die Welt zu tragen.
Ähm ... Ich glaube ...
Wenn die erste Sorge ist,
dass du überhaupt einen Job
und Essen auf dem Tisch hast,
hast du es etwas schwieriger
als wir in der Schweiz.
Dessen müssen wir uns bewusst sein.
Aber du baust
die geilsten Pumptracks,
die am besten funktionieren.
* Dynamische Klänge *
* Jauchzer *
Intensiv arbeiten
und intensiv geniessen,
das ist ganz nach Caluoris Geschmack.
* Gemächliche, drollige Klänge *
Ex-Profimountainbiker Claudio Caluori
holte siebenmal den Schweizer Titel,
bevor er Eishockey-Downhiller
und Pumptrack-Bauer wurde.
Heute sind seine Bikestrecken Kult.
Auf 1'100 m Höhe, in Flims,
sind die Zentrale und das Zuhause
des 42-Jährigen.
Hier tüftelt er
an seinem neuesten Projekt.
Ich bin ein 24-Std.-Mensch.
Ich kann sowohl frühmorgens
wie auch spätabends funktionieren -
aber in der Regel arbeite ich spät.
Letzte Nacht
ging's auch wieder bis um 3 Uhr,
deshalb haben wir heute nicht um
6 Uhr angefangen, sondern erst um 7.
Leben am Limit - das machte Claudio
auch schon als Profibiker.
(Lachend) If I can handle this ...
Kein Berg zu steil,
kein Risiko zu gross.
Vor elf Jahren beendete Claudio
seine Erfolgskarriere
und startete eine neue.
Zusammen mit seinem Team plant
und baut er spezielle Bikestrecken.
Das Geschäft ist lukrativ.
In Chur haben wir den ersten
Pumptrack aus Asphalt gebaut.
Von da aus ist es schweizweit
und global ziemlich explodiert.
Ein Pumptrack ist eigentlich eine
Bahn aus Wellen und Steilwandkurven,
in der man mit dem Bike, BMX,
Inlineskates, Skateboards usw.
fahren kann.
Dazu muss man nicht pedalen,
es reicht,
wenn man durch die Wellen pumpt,
deshalb heisst es Pumptrack.
Dies ist einer in New York,
den wir bauten,
direkt an der Williamsburg Bridge.
Das ist in Washington.
Das hier Indien, Hyderabad.
Das ist Thailand,
Aranyaprathet
an der kambodschanischen Grenze.
Im Voraus diejenigen,
die wir nächste Woche bauen werden.
Das wäre der nächste in Durban.
Äh ... Gut.
Der fällt wohl wieder raus.
Inzwischen
haben wir 160 Tracks um die Welt,
dieses Jahr sollten 60 dazukommen.
Und ähm ...
Dann schauen wir weiter.
Hunger!
- (Mann) Ja.
* Drollige Klänge *
Beim Käsen macht Carlos Marbach
keiner etwas vor.
Seit Jahrzehnten
trägt er das alte Schweizer Handwerk
in die Welt hinaus,
von Südamerika bis in die Mongolei.
So verhilft er kleinen Unternehmen
zum grossen Erfolg.
* Elektronische,
fernöstliche Klänge *
In der mongolischen Hauptstadt
Ulaanbaatar,
in der Heimat von Dschingis Khan,
haben sie jetzt den Käse -
den Schweizer Käse a la Mongolei.
Doch, doch, geh nur!
- Dahin? Kennst du die Strasse?
Dawai, dawai.
- Kennst du die Strasse?
Ja, ich kenne das.
Das ist unser Quartier hier.
Ich weiss, wie ich da rauskomme.
Carlos Marbach ist einer,
der weiss, wo's langgeht -
auf der Strasse und im Leben.
Ganz rechts jetzt weiter,
wo der Rote geht!
Rot, nein! Der Rote.
Der Rote, oh my goodness.
- Ja.
Ich weiss, Mongolen können nicht
unterscheiden zwischen rot und grün.
* Lachen *
Sie fahren bei Ampeln immer durch,
wenn es rot ist.
Der 75-Jährige
ist ein Mann der klaren Worte.
Keine weiss das so gut
wie Narantuy Bataar,
seine mongolische Übersetzerin
und dritte Ehefrau.
Seit zehn Jahren
kommt Käseprofi Carlos hierher
und hilft seinen Kunden
wirtschaftlich auf die Beine.
Wie Enkhee Yadamsuren,
der vier Käsereien
und fünf Restaurants besitzt.
Der gelernte Metallingenieur
hat in Düsseldorf gearbeitet
und Deutsch gelernt.
Mit Carlos
kann er stundenlang fachsimpeln.
Entweder machen wir Qualität,
oder wir machen nichts.
Denn niemand
wartet auf unseren Käse.
Bei der Qualität
gibt es keinen Deal.
Das ist nicht so einfach zu managen
hier in der Mongolei.
Vielleicht
ist es in der Schweiz einfacher,
weil ihr es
schon Tausende Jahre so macht.
Käse ist nicht das einzig typisch
Schweizerische, für das Carlos steht.
Jahrelang war er für das
Schweizerische Katastrophenhilfekorps
und die DEZA unterwegs.
Der heisse Sommer
stellt die Käser vor ein Problem:
zu wenig Wasser,
zu wenig Gras, zu wenig Milch.
Enkhee bekommt Unterstützung.
Hallo, mein Schwiegermütterchen.
Ho! Sain baina uu.
Enkhee ist Vater von fünf Kindern.
Ah!
* Er pfeift. *
Carlos, der Sohn eines Landarbeiters,
ist von den mongolischen Pferden
fasziniert.
Sie haben den Winter
in Freiheit verbracht
und sind nicht mehr
an Menschen gewöhnt.
Hört gar nicht auf ihn.
Aha, gehorcht nicht.
Siehst du?
* Lachen *
Aber die sind noch ganz wild.
Ganz wild, ja. Neu.
* Leise Gespräche, Lachen *
* Drollige Klänge *
Virtuelle Fantasiewelten
sind ihre Spezialität.
Philomena Schwab
ist die wohl profilierteste
Gameentwicklerin der Schweiz.
Eine Anfrage des Silicon Valleys
hat sie abgelehnt,
denn die 29-Jährige träumt davon,
die Schweiz zu einem kleinen
Silicon Valley zu machen.
* Abgehackte, elektronische Klänge *
Als eine der einflussreichsten jungen
Gameentwicklerinnern weltweit
lobte sie das amerikanische
Wirtschaftsmagazin "Forbes".
In diesem Business
musst du schon recht mutig sein.
Viele Gamestudios probieren es
und kriegen es nicht hin.
Es ist schon hart umkämpft,
v.a. bei kleineren Gamestudios.
Philomena Schwab hat das Stray Fawn
Studio vor drei Jahren mitbegründet.
Heute arbeiten hier
zehn junge Künstler.
Hallo zusammen.
- Das hat Zukunft.
Denn die Gamebranche ist weltweit
lukrativer als die Filmbranche.
Was macht Stephi Schönes?
Sind das deine speziellen Brushsets?
- Ja, genau.
Stephi kann super gut zeichnen -
alles wahnsinnig realistisch.
Es geht darum, in dieser
unwirtlichen Welt zu überleben,
mehrere Tage oder sogar Wochen.
Es ist etwas postapokalyptisch,
aber das passt auch
zum aktuellen Klimathema,
das mich und den Rest des Studios
gerade auch stark beschäftigt.
Ich dachte deshalb,
es sei ein spannendes Thema.
Umwelt, Biologie und Genetik.
Das erste Spiel von Philomena
war ein Riesenerfolg.
1 Mio. Fr. brachte es ein.
Geld, das sie für die Entwicklung
neuer Spiele einsetzt.
So, jetzt kann ich mit ihr
hier drüben z.B. ein Nest bauen.
Wenn ich sie dort schlafen lasse,
kriegt sie ein Jungtier.
Das Spannende am Spiel ist,
dass es einen Familienbaum gibt
und jedes Tier
seine eigenen Gene hat.
Hier sehen wir
die Gene der Mutter und des Vaters.
Wenn sie ein Kind haben,
wird das neu gemischt.
So wie es in der Genetik
auch funktioniert.
Das definiert, was ich wie gut kann:
gehen, kämpfen, unter Wasser atmen.
Diese Insel ist sehr friedlich.
Es regnet auch viel.
Das ist gut für die Pflanzen.
Ich kann mich jetzt weiterbewegen.
Mein Baby ist ein Weibchen.
Wir wollten nicht,
dass es zu sehr zum Lernspiel
der Vererbungslehre wird,
mit dominanten und rezessiven Genen,
Sexualchromosomen usw.
Sondern du hast etwas Vorwissen
oder findest es beim Spielen raus.
Philo träumt von einem Game Hub.
Und weil alle ihr Bestes geben,
bezahlt sie den anderen
und sich gleich viel:
um die 5'000 Fr. im Monat.
* Vogelzwitschern, einzelne,
sehnsüchtige Akkordeonmelodien *
Die mongolische Steppe ist weit.
Carlos und Enkhee legen für ihre
Milchtour viele Kilometer zurück.
Urum, Urum.
- Urum, Urum.
Ja, für Nara
müssen wir unbedingt Urum bringen.
Das ist die Milch
von gestern und vorgestern.
Die hat ganz dicken Rahm obendrauf.
Das nennt man Urum.
Das ist eine
Spezialität der hiesigen Herders.
Das ist Milch von heute Morgen.
Ja.
Das ist die Haut.
Auf Berndeutsch
nennt man es "Schlämpe".
Meine Frau mag das wahnsinnig gern.
Wir machen ihr eine Überraschung:
Milchhaut zum Frühstück.
Die Hirtin
erhält umgerechnet 25 Rp. pro Liter.
So viel kostet hier ein Brot.
Ah ja, dachte ich doch.
- Mh!
* Zögerliche Akkordeonklänge *
Die Milchtour zieht sich hin.
Die Nomaden leben weit verstreut
und sind Selbstversorger.
Ihre Grundnahrung
besteht aus Fleisch und Milch.
Gut, gehen wir zum nächsten.
* Sie sprechen Mongolisch. *
Guten Tag.
Sie ist frisch, ca. 1 Std. alt.
Mit solcher Milch kann man
sehr gute Qualität erreichen.
Die Milchkanne ist sauber -
sie wird geputzt.
Sain, sain!
Sie ist ganz sauber, muss man sagen.
Wirklich vorbildlich.
Carlos liebt es,
sein Wissen zu teilen.
Ein Schweizer bin ich.
Ich habe nicht nur den Pass,
sondern auch
einen bodenständigen Beruf: Käser.
Dort lernt man sauberes Arbeiten,
es gibt keine Kompromisse.
Vor 50 Jahren oder mehr
hatte die Alpwirtschaft der Schweiz,
also der Alpkäse,
nicht den besten Ruf.
Heute ist Alpkäse eine Spezialität.
Den Grossteil der Milch
geben die Nomaden den Jungtieren,
mit dem Rest machen sie
Nahrungsmittel für den Winter.
Abgeben können sie nicht viel.
Gibt es noch etwas mehr?
* Sie spricht Mongolisch. *
Fertig, nicht wahr? Ja, ja.
* Fliessende Akkordeonklänge *
Diese Käserei
gehört zum Kloster Amarbayasgalant.
Hier fing Enkhee vor zehn Jahren an,
Käse zu produzieren.
Aber es gab Probleme.
Das änderte sich,
als er Carlos als Coach holte.
Hoi, "Schlämpe"?
Nein, "Schlämpe".
Du kannst dreimal raten für wen.
Der Schweizer Alec
arbeitet auch für Enkhee.
Also, wie sieht's aus?
- Enkhee, ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Ja?
- Ja, alles schön sauber.
Fenster - alles tipptopp.
Boden, die Geräte ...
Nein, das ...
Gratuliere.
Wirklich gut.
Doch eh man sich's versieht,
wird aus Lob Tadel.
Wer arbeitet hier?
Hm?
- Wer arbeitet hier?
Sie.
Wie heisst sie?
- Zegi.
Vegi, komm mal!
Ich muss dir die Ohren langziehen.
Hat dir Enkhee gesagt,
hier auf vier zu stellen?
* Enkhee übersetzt auf Mongolisch. *
- Uguy.
Nur auf drei. Strom hier ist ...
... nicht stabil.
Also wir wollen nicht forcieren.
Nur auf drei.
* Enkhee übersetzt. *
- Ja?
Gut, andere Milch rein!
Die unabhängige Stiftung
Swisscontact
bezahlt Carlos den Flug
und einen symbolischen Lohn.
Sie setzt auf freiwillige
ältere Experten wie ihn,
die ihr Handwerk und damit den Erfolg
in die Welt tragen.
Der Käse, den wir hier herstellen,
muss auch pasteurisiert sein.
Denn die Kühe können -
müssen nicht, aber können -
Krankheitserreger in sich tragen.
Die tötet man
mit der Pasteurisation ab.
Das ist gut, das reicht.
Fertig, fertig, fertig.
Wenn ich sage: "So machen wir's",
dann machen wir es so.
Es gibt keine Kompromisse.
No deal with the quality.
Es muss sauberer sein
als in einem Spital.
Sie hat vergessen, diese zu opfern.
Die was?
- Das Milchopfer!
Weil wir zu schnell ...
- Oh!
Dann eine Schrecksekunde:
Unter Carlos strengem Regime
ging das buddhistische Opferritual
glatt vergessen.
Dieses Versäumnis holt
Enkhees Schwiegermutter sofort nach.
Denn die ersten Tropfen Milch
gehören stets den Göttern.
* Erhabene, weite Klänge *
* Entspannte Klänge *
Nahe der südafrikanischen Stadt
Durban
liegt das Township Chesterville.
Hier finden zwei von drei Einwohnern
keine Arbeit.
Genau hier
braucht es einen Pumptrack,
ist Claudio Caluori überzeugt.
Weil Sport zum friedlichen
Zusammenleben beitrage.
Schnell, das muss geleert werden.
* Rockklänge *
Come on!
Der Chef schont sich nicht,
obwohl es beim Asphaltieren
bis zu 60 °C heiss wird.
Diese Bruthitze zehrt an den Nerven.
Absolut keine Chance,
hier etwas Rechtes zu machen.
Schon nur das Abladen des Asphalts
in die Karrette
ist ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Normalerweise
machen wir ca. 60 t am Tag.
Hier schaffen wir kaum 20 t.
* Pfiffe *
Er kam schon mal 2 Std. zu spät.
Das gibt einen Riesenmurks.
Etwas Gescheites hinkriegen
kann man auch nicht,
aber wir machen es trotzdem.
Drei Männer gehören zu Caluoris Team,
zehn sind einheimische Hilfskräfte.
Yeah, well. Wir sind am Ende.
Wir müssen was ändern oder aufhören.
Eine Schubkarre in 10 Min.,
so geht das einfach nicht.
Hallo,
wir müssen hier vielleicht aufhören.
Wir stecken total in der Scheisse.
Caluoris Notruf an den lokalen
Baumeister zeigt sofort Wirkung.
Schön!
* Er stöhnt. *
Ein Telefonat, ein Zusammenschiss,
und plötzlich geht's.
Man könnte ja
auch ohne Zusammenschiss, aber ...
Auf einmal
kommen die Karretten alle 10 Sek.
Wie sagt man bitte?
Ndiyacela.
- Yat'ela?
- Ndiyacela. Okay.
Ndiyacela. Danke.
Der Auftrag für den Pumptrack
kommt von der Stadt Durban.
Er soll
ein Treffpunkt für alle werden.
Er ist der inoffizielle Chef
des Townships
und unterhält eine Art Privatarmee.
Mit so einem stellt man sich besser
gut, denkt wohl auch Caluori.
All good?
- What's up?
Das war hart heute.
- Ja, ich hab's gesehen.
Einige Arbeiter gingen einfach weg.
Wir stellen sicher,
dass uns niemand dazwischenfunkt.
Ich habe zwölf Soldaten postiert.
Wir müssen alles wissen,
was in der Gemeinde geschieht.
Wir sind überall dabei.
30 % eines jeden Projektes
gehen an uns.
Weil der Pumptrack für Kinder
armer Familien gedacht ist,
hat Caluori die Planungsarbeiten
nicht verrechnet.
Für die Fertigstellung
bleibt ihnen gerade noch ein Tag.
Zurück nach Zürich.
Die Gameentwicklerin Philomena Schwab
wohnt in einer WG in Schwamendingen.
Zusammen mit Mutter Ursula.
Morgen bist du nicht hier, oder?
- Abends?
Nein, abends nicht.
Die beiden lassen sich viel Freiheit.
Meine Mutter fragt mich nur,
wo ich abends bin,
um zu wissen,
ob wir zusammen kochen.
Sonst würde ich das nicht fragen.
- Nein, oder?
Zum Glück nicht.
Ursula hat ihre Tochter
alleine grossgezogen.
Das Haushaltsbudget war knapp.
Ja, hol dir die Decke.
Gib sie mir unter dem Tisch durch!
* Sie lacht. *
Super.
Spiele haben Mutter und Tochter
immer geliebt.
Ursula mag Brettspiele,
die virtuelle Welt ist ihr fremd.
Was?
Für Philo ist beides inspirierend.
Du gibst alles. - Jetzt du.
- Ich kann immer noch nicht.
Immer noch nicht.
Philomenas Mutter
stand immer hinter ihr.
Dass sie schlau ist,
wusste ich schon immer.
In welche Richtung vielleicht nicht,
aber dass sie etwas Besonderes
macht, dachte ich schon.
Auch Coiffeuse wäre schön gewesen,
wäre das ihre Leidenschaft gewesen.
Für mich ist wichtig, dass ...
... sie lebt,
was ihre Leidenschaft ist.
Das war immer mein Wunsch.
Für mein Kind und das Leben.
Ah, warte.
Auch die smarte Jungunternehmerin
hat einen Wunsch:
Es gibt Verschiedenes,
das ich gerne machen würde,
wenn wir mehr Geld hätten ...
Hast du etwas Gutes gezogen?
Wir haben das ganze Projekt ...
Nein!
* Ursula lacht. *
Ich erzähle über die Zukunft,
und du machst mich fertig.
Gut gemacht -
schau, ich habe noch x ...
Du bist schon gut in diesem Spiel.
Mit mehr Geld
würden wir uns
ein cooles Haus kaufen, oder?
Du hättest Hühner und
ich könnte immer Spiegeleier essen.
Also, ich würde sagen,
ich habe gewonnen. - So was von.
Nur weil man Gamedesigner ist,
heisst das nicht,
dass man nicht mal verlieren kann.
Das letzte Mal hast du gewonnen,
das gleicht sich immer wieder aus.
* Sehnsüchtige Akkordeonklänge *
Ein Mönch, der sich in der Schweiz
in den Käse verliebte,
liess hier eine Käserei erbauen,
um diese Köstlichkeit
selber herzustellen.
* Sie sprechen Mongolisch. *
Er holte Enkhee dazu,
und dieser bat Carlos um Hilfe.
Für Carlos muss er
lediglich Kost und Logis übernehmen.
Sehr zufrieden.
Das gibt einen super Käse.
Nein, alles reingeben. Alles ...
No, no, no.
Alles!
Du musst immer gleich gross machen!
Vier volle.
Aufschreiben: 10.53 Uhr!
So. Wenden!
(Mann) Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, Käse sind rund,
alles in Ordnung.
Das ist Tradition.
Den ersten viereckigen Käse
machte man in der Schweiz
in den 50er-Jahren.
Aber man sagt: "Ein Käse muss rund
sein, damit man ihn rollen kann."
Der Käse ist weitherum beliebt,
und Unternehmer Enkhee
darf auf baldigen Gewinn hoffen.
Ich muss schauen,
wie sie runterfällt.
Die Liebesgeschichte
von Nara und Carlos
nahm in der mongolischen Steppe
ihren Anfang.
Das war vor 15 Jahren.
Küssli, ciao.
Und weg galoppiert sie.
Ja, da ist sie
voll in ihrem Element.
Sie ritt schon als Kind immer.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonklänge *
Das war sehr gut. Sehr gut.
Das war prima, danke.
Tipptopp.
Die Arbeiter fragten mich mal,
ob ich wisse,
dass Nara in drei Jahren stirbt.
Ich sagte: "Ach wo!"
Und dann ...
Ich fragte sie:
"Wieso hast du mir das nie gesagt?"
Sie sagte: "Was soll ich sagen ...
Es kann mich ja niemand operieren."
Ich habe dann mit Schweizer
Chirurgen Kontakt aufgenommen,
die schon hier operiert hatten.
Sie sagten,
wir finden schon eine Lösung.
Es war schwierig,
aber ich finde es gut.
Ja, Kari macht es gut.
Die Herzoperation war 2004,
sechs Jahre später
haben die beiden geheiratet.
Auch das eine Erfolgsgeschichte.
* Entspannte, karibische Klänge *
In der südafrikanischen Stadt Durban
muss Claudio Caluori in aller Früh
sein Tagesprogramm ändern.
Um 17.30 Uhr ist mein Flug.
Ich muss um 16.30 Uhr da sein.
Von Chesterville muss ich
spätestens um 14.30 Uhr wegfahren.
In Thailand soll
ein neuer Pumptrack entstehen.
Der Sponsor will Claudio vorher in
London treffen. Das erhöht den Druck.
Wir warten auf den Asphalt.
Der hat
wie üblich 1 Std. Verspätung.
Ich hoffe, es bleibt bei 1 Std.
Dauert es länger, wird es eng,
um es fertigzukriegen,
bevor ich gehen muss.
Sani bonani.
- (Alle) Hey.
Unjani?
Yapila?
* Die Männer
antworten durcheinander. *
Seid ihr müde von gestern?
Ja, das war Knochenarbeit!
Nur noch einen Truck,
dann sind wir fertig.
Jetzt warten wir
seit 2 Std. auf den Asphalt.
Es beginnt zu regnen.
Wir sollten in 4 Std. fertig sein,
sogar weniger.
Irgendwie
wird es etwas unrealistisch.
Alright!
Geht doch.
Okay, Attacke!
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Ich sagte schon immer,
am Limit sei es am schönsten.
Und hier gibt's ganz viel Limit.
Ab und zu muss ich
aber auch wieder rauskommen,
ich bin fast konstant dort.
Alright.
Der selbsternannte Quartierchef
bereitet schon mal
das anstehende Barbecue vor.
Das war einer der Härteren.
Jetzt ist gut. Saubere Sache.
Eine ziemliche Erleichterung,
wenn es durch ist.
Vielen Dank!
Thank you, siyabonga.
Möchtest du Fleisch?
- Nein, bin immer noch Vegetarier.
Na dann, alles Gute, bis bald.
- Yeah.
Siyabonga! Thank you. See you soon.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Auch in der kroatischen Stadt
Dubrovnik gilt:
Ohne Fleiss kein Preis.
Philomena Schwab
und ihr Freund Don Schmocker,
der ebenfalls erfolgreich
Spiele entwickelt, haben viel vor.
Es ist wunderschön.
Fast wie in den Ferien.
Schau, da baden welche.
Ich will auch baden.
Es ist ziemlich blau.
- Super blau und klar.
Jetzt gehen wir zur Konferenz,
ich brauche meinen Badge.
Du hast deinen schon, oder?
- Ja.
Dann gehe ich um 11.45 Uhr pitchen.
Genau 5 Min. habe ich Zeit,
dann schneiden sie einen ab.
So lange kann man
über das Game erzählen.
Da kommen Investoren,
Publisher und Presseleute,
die man zu beeindrucken
versuchen kann.
* Elektronische Klänge *
Die Reboots ist eines der weltweit
grössten Gameentwicklertreffen.
Viele einflussreiche Menschen
kommen hier zusammen.
Philomena nutzt die Gunst der Stunde.
Great.
Ich heisse Philomena.
Ich bin Mitgründerin und Spiel-
entwicklerin von Stray Fawn Studio.
Wir sind ein kleines Team
von zehn Personen in Zürich,
und wir arbeiten
an unserem zweiten Spiel,
das Nimbatus, der Weltraumerbauer,
heisst.
Was ist Nimbatus?
Es ist ein Action-Simulations-Game.
* Metallischer Aufprall *
Das Spiel finanziert sich
im Frühstadium selbst.
Aber wir suchen die Unterstützung
von Publishers, v.a. in Asien.
Dort gibt es viel Potenzial
bezüglich Distribution
und Marketing.
Und wir sind auch
für andere Vorschläge offen.
Super, awesome.
And actually within our time frame.
Hey.
Wir sind chinesische Publishers.
- Oh, gut.
Faszinierend,
ein grossartiges Spiel.
Das hat Riesenpotenzial.
Der Pool lockt,
aber Erfolg fordert Einsatz.
Bereits um 15 Uhr
ist Philomenas nächster Auftritt.
Ob ich perfektionistisch bin
oder nicht, kommt aufs Thema an.
Bei Gewissem überhaupt nicht,
aber bei Dingen, die mich
sehr interessieren, schon ziemlich.
Ich will schon schauen,
dass ich eine gute Rede mache,
und nicht
die Zeit anderer verschwende.
Sie sitzen extra 30 Min. rein.
Wenn ich dann nichts Interessantes
erzähle, ist das schade.
Wer gehört werden will,
muss gut auftreten.
Philo habe sich das
antrainieren müssen, sagt sie.
Heute gibt sie selbstbewusst Tipps,
wie man sich
die Treue der Gamer sichert.
Here's one more if anybody wants it.
Ist der Aufbau einer Gamergruppe
wichtig für finanziellen Erfolg?
Wir denken: ja.
Wir wussten: Mit 50'000 Kopien
erreichen wir die Gewinnzone.
Wir machten den Spielern klar:
Wenn wir das nicht hinkriegen,
ist Schluss mit Updates.
Dann schrieben wir ihnen Vorschläge,
wie sie uns unterstützen können.
"Wendet euch an eure Lieblings-
YouTuber, -Twitch-Streamer,
euren Lieblingskanal,
postet es auf Social Media
und bringt es unter die Leute."
Und sie machten uns bekannt,
indem sie uns überall erwähnten.
Auch in dieser Branche
ist Networking Teil des Erfolgs.
Hi.
- Valentina from Level Up.
Oh, cool! Nice to meet you.
Können wir ein Bild von uns machen?
- Klar.
Ich bin ein Blogger.
Nach diesem ereignisreichen Tag
hat die Jungunternehmerin
endlich einen Moment für sich.
Ich habe
nicht wirklich ein Lebensziel.
Als Teenager sagte ich immer:
"Nein, jetzt muss ich schon wieder
den ganzen Tag etwas machen,
von dem mir jemand sagt,
ich solle es spannend finden."
Das fand ich gar nicht cool.
Wenn ich bis zum Schluss immer
meine eigenen Entscheidungen treffen
und die Konsequenzen tragen kann,
bin ich schon ganz zufrieden.
Genau so klingt
erfolgreiches Unternehmertum.
Vorhin klatschte mir Wasser ins
Gesicht - schau auf meiner Brille!
Jetzt ist es schon besser,
aber es ist einfach kalt.
Auch Claudio
kann einen Erfolg verbuchen.
Nach seinem 48-Std.-Trip nach London
hat der thailändische Investor
den Vertrag unterzeichnet.
Sani bonani.
Das ist ein anderes Township,
in dem wir vor einem Jahr
einen Pumptrack bauten.
So sieht auch der in Chesterville
aus, wenn er fertig ist.
In Chesterville braucht es noch
die Begrünung und die roten Linien.
Schauen wir mal, was da so läuft.
Seine Pumptracks eröffnen den Kindern
eine neue Welt, glaubt er.
Darum hat er ihnen diese Anlage
letztes Jahr geschenkt.
Aber deine Bremse ist blockiert.
Du hättest gewinnen können!
Ich hoffe, sie ist nicht
mit angezogenen Bremsen gefahren -
sonst hätte sie
wohl noch viel besser sein können.
Jetzt läuft's.
Caluori sponsert das Mädchenteam.
Ich liebe es, hier Leute zu treffen.
Vorher konnte ich
nicht mit fremden Menschen sprechen,
aber diese Scheu
habe ich überwunden.
Jetzt kann ich mit allen sprechen,
so wie ich es
gerade mit Claudio tue.
Machen wir mal eine Runde!
Mit dabei ist Aphiwe Goge.
Sie ist 13-jährig.
Und hat das ziemlich im Griff,
wie's aussieht.
Good job!
* Rockige Klänge *
Going fast, ey?
Caluori hofft,
dass die Mädchen später
an einem Weltcup teilnehmen können.
Es ist verdammt geil.
Egal, woher sie kommen, welche
Herkunft sie haben, wo sie wohnen -
sie haben immer Freude.
Yeah, no pedaling!
* Sanfte Klänge *
Es macht mich
schon immer sehr emotional.
Ich muss mich zusammenreissen.
Es gibt nichts Cooleres, als wenn
das, was man als Arbeit macht,
anderen Menschen Freude bereitet -
das ist der Hammer.
Noch mehr Schweizer
Erfolgsgeschichten in einer Woche:
Eines der bekanntesten
Stickereiunternehmen der Schweiz
führt Caroline Forster als Co-CEO
in vierter Generation.
Sogar Michelle Obama
trägt diese Kreationen.
Hans Rudolf Herren hat in Afrika
Millionen Menschen
vor dem Hungertod bewahrt.
Bill Clinton, Prinz Charles
und Margaret Thatcher danken es ihm.
Simon Rindlisbacher
ist Fünfsterne-Hotelier in Vietnam.
Sein Personal weiss:
Qualität geht ihm über alles.
Das ist sein Erfolgsrezept.